I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Angela just turned out the lights in the studio. Okay, here's the thing.
There's a lot of buttons. This is what I want from a light switch. I want one button. There's four buttons over there, Jenna. There's more than four. You guys, it is a complicated light switch. Thank you. But we like to listen to our theme song to get in the mood, so we're listening to it
with you. All during our theme song, Angela is pressing the buttons. The lights are going up, they're going down, they're fading in. There's track lighting, then there's these other kind of lights and ceiling lights. Then there's four lamps. We should turn some of the lamps on. That might help me. We need the light because our eyes are fading.
Because I can't see, guys. That's what's happening. But all right, we're here. The lights are on and we are ready. We are ready for lecture circuit part one, season five, episode 16, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Ken Quapas. It's an official two-parter. It is, and I've got a whole fast fact about it.
Oh, look how your face just lit up. You're so excited. I am. Here is your summary. Michael, accompanied by Pam, is embarking on a three-day lecture tour of the nearby Dunder Mifflin branches. I need to stop you one second. Three days.
Yeah. Three days. Pam is going to be on the road with Michael. And she's so cheery about it. At the beginning. Well, you know, Michael's branch is outselling all the other branches. David Wallace is perplexed. What's that secret sauce?
Please go to the other branches and tell them all about it. Well, they're going to start in Utica. This is where they're going to run into Karen and they are met with a surprise. But back in Scranton, we reveal that Jim and Dwight are now the co-heads of the party planning committee and they forgot Kelly's birthday. And she is ticked off. Oh, that is an understatement. Meanwhile, Andy has a crush on one of Stanley's clients.
Fast fact number one. Lecture Circuit is a two-part episode. It aired two different weeks and this is our first episode to ever feature a to be continued message, you know, at the end of the episode. But Lecture Circuit was not written as two episodes. It was one script, like your regular 41 pages long. We shot it in five days. So why did they make it a two-part, or Jenna?
I will tell you. I thought you might. I was trading emails with director Ken Quapas. He told me that when they went to assemble it in the editing room, there was so much good stuff. His director's cut was 35 minutes long. He showed it to Greg and he said, Greg, I can't cut anymore. That's it.
It's got to be 35 minutes, Greg. Yeah. Make it supersize. Yeah. Or something. Something. We can't lose any of this. Let's turn it into two episodes.
And Ken said he was thrilled. That's amazing. That's how good it was. Yeah. Mindy and Ken turned in that good of an episode. Well, fast fact number two, when they broke up the episode into two episodes, they did actually need more storylines to fill out each half. So they knew that the lecture circuit story and the birthday party story would remain
in both episodes, but it actually wasn't enough for two complete episodes. So they had to write two more stories. And what were those? I will tell you. For this episode, they added the storyline of Andy wanting to date Stanley's client, Julia. Yeah. That makes sense because in the original script, it's not in there at all.
No. In the second half, which we will get to next week, they wrote a very interesting storyline for you and your cats. Oh, yeah. I have stories, guys. So let's talk about this storyline with Stanley and his client, Julia, that they added. The reason that he doesn't meet with his client in the conference room is because the conference room was busy being a birthday party.
Sure. It was being decorated. So they did all of that in the break room, and also that way they could insert it into the episode wherever they wanted, and it wouldn't affect any of the continuity of the other story. And they could shoot it later because that's what we did. Yes. We shot these two additional storylines a full month later.
That was the crazy thing. For me, they were like, okay, you have a whole storyline. It's going to be in lecture circuit. We're shooting it in three weeks. Yeah. What? Because they had to write it. Should we move on to fast-fac number three?
Well, you sound eager. I think we should. Well, it's a location breakdown. You love a location breakdown. I really do. I know. I love knowing where we made this stuff happen. Yeah.
You want to be in the room where it happens? Hamilton. Hey. Room where it happens. I love that. I really love that song. I do, too. Okay.
We had a fan question from Joe S. Jenna, did you and Steve film your scenes in the car in a single day or multiple days? And where did you drive around to film the car scenes? I'll tell you. We shot all of the driving scenes for both lecture circuit one and lecture circuit part two on the same one day. Oh, wow. So you had a full day in the car.
Yep. Just driving around. Just driving around. It was Wednesday, November 5th. Look at you. Someone got the call sheet and looked at it. And that someone is Jenna Fisher. Yes, thanks to James Cary.
So here's where we went. We made a loop of three streets in North Hollywood. Nordof, Sadakoy, and Plummer. I recognize Sadakoy. Yeah. That's also the street that our sound stages were on. That's the street we drove on every single day. To get to work.
Yeah. I will tell you, I was not actually driving in these scenes. You weren't? No. You did some good, fakie driving. Thank you so much. I was going to ask you if you drove at all. I did not.
Oh. They had the car loaded onto a rig and it was being pulled by a precision driver. OK. I'm not much of a precision driver. I wouldn't describe myself that way at all. Precision is not the word I would think of to describe my driving. Jenna, I've ridden with you in a car. I know.
You know, you're a very safe driver. But you, what are you going to say? You, I don't know, it's like you grip the wheel with both hands. I do. I'm a 10 and two. You're a 10 and two. And then you just kind of, you look straight ahead. And sometimes I'm like, you know, you can go around them, Jenna.
There's a whole lane that's empty right next to you. We've been behind Pokey Pokerson for like half an hour. 10 and two, turn a little bit and go around them. Can I say something right now? This driving does actually sound very precise. OK. Well, maybe I am a precision driver and I don't know it. You're a slow precision driver.
You're not going to be taking any courses where you're like zipping around any cones. You'll get around them. Oh, sorry. Are you doing cone courses in your time? Yeah. Is that your hobby? Do you not know this about me? A freaking badass.
Like I do. I actually, by the way, I did pull off the road. Like we did all that driving sequence. I was driving. Went to why it runs me off the road. That was me. Oh, yeah. What do you want?
What do you want? I want my precision driving trophy. It's a little gold, like street cone. All right. I'll find one for you and I will get it for you. OK. So anyway, you were not driving, but you shot all in one day. We shot it all in one day.
And then the next day, we shot everything at the Utica branch. And we started with all of the interior scenes. And we shot at this building in Chatsworth, California. It was on Hordoff Street. And we started very early that day. We started at 5.30 in the morning. That was your call time? Yeah.
And the crew call was 6.30 and the shooting call was 6.45. What that means is that we had the goal of arriving at 5.30, rehearsing at 6.30, and we had to start shooting by 6.45 a.m. That's an early day. And we did it. All right. So before we go to break, lady, I think we should give a little book update. Book update?
Office BFFs? Office BFFs is the name of our book that we have been working on for... Oh, good Lord. Three years. More than I can imagine. Oh, my goodness. We've been sharing on our Instagram, like our journey as we're writing this together. And guess what?
Well, you might know if you follow us. We finished our manuscript. We turned in our manuscript. Someone throw some confetti. Please. Your husband, Josh, did throw confetti when you told him that we had finished it. It was so sweet. But now we are in this really fun part where we are going through all of our photos.
So many photos. And they're so good. Because you guys, the reason we wanted to write this book in the first place was because we did this big clean out of our garages and your shed and my basement. Oh, my gosh. Basically, it's everywhere we stash stuff. Yeah. And you know what we found out?
What did we find? We're big stashers. We did not need to find that out, lady. I think we knew that. Oh, my gosh. But it's true. And we saved everything. Every scrap of paper.
Every ticket stub. Here's the other thing, too. Not only do we save everything, but like our family does. I have a whole envelope from my cousin Carol of all of these clippings. Thank you, Carol. Well, all of this stuff is going in the book. I don't know that we can put all of it in the book. The book could be like 800 pages.
That's true. Some of this stuff is going in the book, but it's all really fun. And you guys, I just am so excited for you to get it and to hold it in your hands and to have it. Me, too. I'm excited to go on our book tour. What? Lady, you know, when your book comes out, you go on a tour and you sign it and you meet
people. We're going to get to go on like a lady's road trip. A road trip. I hadn't even thought that far ahead. I'm sorry I'm yelling. I'm so excited. Okay. You know, this has been something I've wanted for a long time, which is a BFF road trip.
I know it's going to happen. Like a real deal road trip where we go to multiple cities. Well, it's happening. Get ready for it. Office BFFs with all our hoarded stuff and all of our great stories, it's coming your way soon. Oh my God. I didn't even think about going on tour.
Well, there you go. There's our book update, life update. Hit the road update. Look, I'm already excited. The book is not even done and I'm like planning our road trip. Oh, I have my places I like to stop and snack at. What are they? Where will I be snacking?
I love a good, like just greasy burger joint. For sure. Right? Mm-hmm. Also, I love the Frito chili chips. You know? Oh, really? You're going to eat Frito chili chips around me?
Everyone says they stink up the room. It's so stinky lately. I know. I love them. Okay. They're one of my go-to road trip snacks. Okay. Okay.
All right. We're going to go to break now and I'm going to just try to convince Angela to eat regular Fritos. I love a regular Frito, especially with some queso. Oh, you know what I love a regular Frito with? What? A Frito chili pie. I'm so hungry now.
Like in the bag. I know. Give it to me. All right. We'll be back in a second. We are back. We're in this episode now. Michael, you guys.
Oh, my gosh. A phone guy came in to fix his phone and showed him the PA system. You can't show Michael. You got the office PA system? You definitely cannot. He is really goofing about now. Yeah. He pretends to be a plane captain, a ghost.
He forgets the intercom is on while he's talking to his doctor about his mole. He calls Toby into the principal's office for waiting his bed. I think we should hear it. Can you play the clip? Yeah. Is your captain speaking? The office will be fine and an altitude of two stories. Please look out your left-hand window and you will see advanced refrigeration.
I am the ghost that salesman passed. Do not come near me. Yes, Michael Scott for Dr. Jocelyn, please. Hello, doctor. I was just following up about my mole again. Now, I was looking online about sebaceous snips that I had not been squeezing in. Oh. Could I stick it with a pen?
Don't be blundered into the principal's office, your mother calls, and it appears that you wet the bed again. No, you have to get home and wash your sheets because they're yellow and they're wet with your urine. My personal favorite part of that is the coughing. Yes. I loved listening to him cough. It reminded me of the Tiramisu coughing fit that he had on the phone with David Walton.
Steve Krull is a master at fake laughing and fake coughing. Yeah. You believe it? We had a fan question from Virginia S. When Michael is on the PA system, were any of his announcements improvised or were they all in the script? For example, the announcement that Toby has wet his bed is hilarious. All right. They had several alts and the one that was actually in the script for Toby read like
this, Toby Flenderson to the principal's office, you are in trouble for sucking. That's pretty good. That's what was in the script. Well I read the script while I watched this portion and I would say that a lot of it was scripted but Steve definitely did do improvisations off of what was written. And I'm sure Mindy was pitching things to him too on the day. Yes. But I noticed that the line about Ghost of Christmas Pass that was scripted but the coughing
bit was not in the script. Really quickly. I feel like we need to point out something at 27 seconds. What's that? What's up with Angela's outfit? What is it? It is a poofy, floofy sweater, but it's like poofy like at the shoulder. That was really in and I feel like that's coming back.
What? The arms. Oh. We went through a real Shakespeare Renaissance fare thing back then. I'm not here for it. It's coming back, lady. Great. You know what I found in my closet?
How do I describe this? I found a ribbon on a hanger. And then clipped to the ribbon were various flowers that I could put in my hair or on my lapel. You could adorn your outfit. Like one of the flowers was like a fabric flower that you would clip on your blazer. Oh, yeah. Was that in for a while?
Why do I have seven flowers to clip to myself? I don't know. It feels very much like a pretty and pink, kind of like a molly ring wall. I looked at it. Put the flower on her hat. Yeah. It brought back no memories when I looked at it. Two of the flowers were like Hawaiian flowers.
I clearly bought them to clip in my hair while on a trip to Hawaii. But the rest were more casual, more everyday. But I'm going to clip one on my blazer lapel when we do our book tour. All right. I'm planting that seed now. I can't wait. It's going to make me real happy. What I won't have on our book tour is a poofy sleeve sweater because at my age, I don't need
any extra poofs. You know what? I'm going to say you will wear that on our book tour. No. Don't say that. Poofy sweater thing and flower lapel. Who are we on this book tour? I don't know.
We're interesting people. Well, we'll see. Not trust well, but interesting. All right. Let's get started. This episode opens with Michael exiting a motel room. He knocks on the neighboring door and out comes Pam. Yes.
In the shooting draft of our script, it says Michael knocks on Pam's door. They say good morning. That's it. They don't even have dialogue written out for you guys. You just sort of greet each other. This is not in the script. When Michael knocks says hello, good morning, Pam says good morning, and then Michael says you ready?
And we're off like a herd of turtles that is not in the script. I think Steve improvised that. I will tell you, I absolutely loved doing this episode because I got Steve all to myself. I bet. Just scene after scene of me and Steve, and I loved it. Some of my favorite times in the office were when I just got to have days with Steve, me and Steve. I know.
They were brief and few and far between because, you know, Angela Martin hated him, but those were always such a delight. Well, I love this scene of me putting the luggage into the back of the car. I did too. I'm sorry. I thought I did. I'm going to toot my own horn. I thought my heavy luggage acting was superb.
It was so great that I wrote a question for you. Here's my fan question. Okay. What was in the bag? It looked really heavy. There was almost nothing in that bag. That was all me. Thank you.
I mean, I couldn't be prouder of that. You know what? I want to cone award for my precision driving. I'm going to get you a little tiny suitcase. Thank you. That says great prop work. Prop work award. I don't know if you noticed, but we got a lot of mail about this car.
Adele M wrote in and said, whose maroon Ford is Pam driving? I thought she had a Yaris and Michael had a PT cruiser. What is this car? Exactly. Is it a rental car? Listen to this. What? This is a gem from Randy Cordray.
He said in an early concept meeting for this episode, it was discussed that Michael would need extra trunk space for all of his props and his trunk and all that stuff and that it just wouldn't fit in his PT cruiser. So they said that they thought it would be funny if Michael had to ask the company to provide him with a Lincoln town car that Pam would drive him around in. But corporate would only approve a cheaper Crown Victoria. So this was always intended to be like a scripted moment where we would explain this. But in the end, it never made the shooting draft.
So it comes off a bit confusing, but this was like a whole joke. I love it because Michael thinks he's carrot top, right? So he's got to have all of his props and his trunks of crazy gadgets and things. I mean, I'm surprised he didn't dress in a costume. I was too, but yet he gives Pam like some sass about her outfit and says, don't you know what a magician's assistant looks like? I googled magician's assistant costume. There's a lot of fishnet.
There's some short shorts. There's a bustier. There's a top hat. Yeah, sometimes a skirt. It's a very sexy looking outfit. Yeah. Well, Pam wore her tan cardigan. It's new.
I had such a hard time getting through that line because of course we knew that line was going to be in the script. So when we picked my outfit for this episode, we thought it was very funny that her new cardigan was like beige was beige. I have another amazing tidbit about this car before we get on the road. The toboggan. Yeah. That's on top of the car.
All right. The reason that's there is because there was a scene that was written as a tag for this episode. And the scene was going to be Michael and Pam going down a snowy hill on that toboggan. Why didn't that happen? I need to see that. Yes. Well, we'd have to go somewhere with snow.
Randy said they went out to scout a snowy mountain. And the photos that they came back with, it just didn't look great. There just wasn't a lot of snow happening at the time that we were shooting this episode. We couldn't go all the way to Mammoth, which is five hours away, right? We had to find some place that was relatively close and there just was no snow, so we never shot it. But there were two options. One was that Michael was going to be going down the hill on the toboggan and Pam was
just going to be kind of like standing there, right? And the other version is that Pam and Michael are sledding down together, but midway down the hill, Pam falls off and rolls to the bottom. And Michael says, again! Well, maybe I'm glad you didn't have to do that, Jenna Fisher. No, I so wish I could have gone sledding with Steve. I so wish. That would have been a blast.
Back at Dundermifflin, Kelly arrives to work and she is really upset. Yeah. I would like to note at four minutes, 10 seconds, there is a big door slam. Guys, that front door did not slam. No. It did not. In fact, it had that little suspension thing, you know, that suspension bracket, so it just would shut like heeee.
So that was added in post. They had to make it a silent door because a lot of times people would have to enter and we'd be in the middle of a scene and then you would have heard kajunk. Right. So it was a heeee. Does not slam. Right. But they needed to really sell how mad Kelly was.
So they put it in. Fakey slam. Well, Mindy says, screw you to Jim and Dwight. She storms off and then Phyllis explains that Kelly is upset because they forgot her birthday yesterday. Yeah. We got a piece of mail. Okay.
From Zoe S. Here's what Zoe has to say. In this episode, it's the day after Kelly's birthday, Jim and Dwight forgot. Phyllis knew it was Kelly's birthday yesterday. But Kelly says nobody wished her a happy birthday. Zoe would like to know, why didn't Phyllis wish Kelly a happy birthday if she knew? I mean, it's one thing that Phyllis wants to make Jim and Dwight look bad, but Phyllis showed some real sass to Kelly on her birthday. Thank you, Zoe.
This is what Angela Martin had to deal with day in and day out. The secret Phyllis sass that people don't see, they just see, oh nice Phyllis, but there's a deep current of deep dark secret Phyllis sass, passive aggressive Phyllis sass. This leads us into a talking head that I know these two boys loved filming. Well they couldn't get through it. They couldn't get through this whole episode. I'm going to be bringing up some bloopers in a minute. It started with the side by side talking head.
And if you read this talking head in the shooting draft, what made it to screen, you can see they were having some fun. They had some improv around what was written. The very top, when Jim says, go ahead and Dwight goes, no, you go ahead, you do it. Jim goes, okay. And Dwight goes, I insist. That was all improvised. Then they get into the part, you know, where they're telling that Angela was blackmailed
by Phyllis. That's all scripted. But then Dwight goes, what he said was, and he puts a finger towards Jim's face and Jim pushes it away and goes, just easy. That's all improv guys. That's just these two fellas having some fun. I think I could have told you all that because I know these two so well. And I know the bits that they would do off camera.
What about the one at the end? That was all improv too. That whole like, that's on my side. And then Jim's like, so this was fun. Yes. That's just them playing around. Yeah. That's their chemistry.
Well, after that talking head, we have a Kelly talking head where she explains that yesterday was her birthday. Everybody forgot. We see that she got all dressed up. There wasn't a party. This one minute is full of some amazing background catches. Oh, let's hear them. The first one is a fan catch from Ryan W. When they show Kelly all dressed up for her birthday
during her talking head in the background on Dwight's desk, you can see his bobble head from Angela. Oh, it's back on the desk. I looked at it. Yes. And it's 10 seconds bobble head. But also, this is the one I noticed, Creed is milling around in Michael's office. What?
Yeah. He's just milling around in there. What the heck? What's he doing in there? I don't know. I don't either. Those are my background catches. Those are good catches.
Jenna, we all know that Ryan had his list. Remember when he came back? Yes. When he kept writing down names. Did you know that Angela Martin also has her list? No. She calls it her enemy list. She's not subtle.
And it all comes up in a scene that was deleted between Jim Dwight and Angela. She's turning over her party planning committee box of items. Here it is. I reprinted my vendors list for parties. It's a list of birthdays, half birthdays, minutes from past parties, and an enemy's list. You're going to need it. If there's some cat stuff mixed in here, I'd appreciate you returning it to me.
Of course. I wish you two the best of luck. Thank you. Angela, Dwight and I would like to say that we'd be honored if you would stay on as a member of the committee. And we think you could even run it and take care of everything and we would not get in your way. Well, that is a great idea.
Nice try. It's your problem now. I want to say I spit out my coffee when you explained that you had minutes for the parties. She's documenting everything that happens at these parties and she has an enemy's list. Wow. I mean, those are scenes I would have loved to see. Toboggan scene. Yeah.
Did Pam want to read the minutes of a party? Yeah. I agree. Well, back in the car, Pam wants to turn on the radio, but Michael needs silence or Sam Kinnison in order to prepare. One of those two. Sam Kinnison, comedian that yelled. His whole stand-up routine was yelling.
Yes. He needs one of those two things. But that's okay. Pam's just going to sing to herself. But then Michael asked Pam if she's nervous about seeing Karen today. He says, is that why you wore makeup today? And Pam's like, what? What?
No. I loved that line. I don't know why. Oh, because it's just one of those statements that completely rattles you. And also because I have so done that. Yes. I have so juged up a little extra. And if someone points it out, then you get embarrassed.
Yes. Yeah. Oh, that was such good writing. So now we start that storyline that Jenna mentioned that we added to fill out the script. Stanley is going to escort in Julia, his client. And I want you to notice they did not use the front door. No. Whoever comes in this way, no one.
And the reason they did that was so that they would not have to pass by the conference room because they didn't know where they were going to put this entrance. And they just didn't want it to mess up whatever Dwight and Jim might have done or not done to the conference room yet. Yes, so they strategically position the camera so you see them coming in by that door by the file cabinet. Yeah. The only other time we've seen that door was during the fire drill.
Yeah. Basically. And I have to tell you, in my mind, I have no idea where that goes. Where does that go? We don't know. We don't know. I know where the front door goes. Yeah.
There's also that door by the break room. Right. Where does that go? Well, we think it goes to the parking lot because Michael and Dwight chased each other, remember? Oh, yeah. I can't put it together in my head. I can't.
Because obviously, those doors went literally nowhere. They went to snacks backstage is where they went. But yes, they entered that way so we could place this new storyline anywhere we wanted. Yes. Andy notices Julia. He is immediately smitten. Does anybody fall in love at first sight more than Andy? No, Andy is so…
Maybe Michael. Maybe Michael. This might be what they have in common. They fall in love instantly. Yeah. They fall in love with a chair model. Do you know what I'm saying? Yes, I'm sure.
Right. I'm sorry. It's definitely Michael. Yes. And Phyllis immediately is like, she's out of your league. Well, Andy doesn't care that she's out of his league. He's going to go for it. He has such a great talking head.
It was like so well written when he's like, I'm single now and there's an epic showdown between the gnarred dog and crippling despair. Oh my gosh. I know. Well, Jim and Dwight are also going to try and apologize to Kelly. They want to make it up to her and she does this great passive aggressive thing that we know she doesn't mean where she says, you know what, all I want is for this to never happen to another person.
Oh, I know. That's what I want. Oh, I know. Well, they barely got through this scene. I don't know how they have a usable take. And then they continue breaking throughout the whole rest of the script. We got to hear some of these bloopers. We just want to say we're very sorry.
Screw you guys. You're dead to me. If you say screw you one more time. Screw you, beat farmer. Whoa. Okay, guys. I did the face you like. If you say screw you one more time.
Let's screw you, beat farmer. Hey, guys. Cool. Stop doing that. Yeah. It makes no sense. If you say screw you one more time. Screw you, beat farmer.
Hey, guys, just cool it. You knew. You knew that one. Dude, you knew that one. Basically the dynamics of shit, all right, basically in the workplace. There's always a theme, idiot. Okay, here's what I have to say. I can tell from listening to John laugh that he's crying and he has bent over.
嘿，大家，冷静点。你们知道。你们知道那个。老兄，你们知道那个。基本上就是废话的动态，好吗，基本上在职场上。总有一个主题，白痴。好吧，我有话要说。我从听约翰的笑声中听出他在哭，而且他已经弯下腰了。
Yes. He's like in full flop. Yeah. He has lost it. One of the hardest times I ever laughed was doing a scene with Mindy and Rain because when you put Mindy and Rain together, nobody is in control. There's no, the two of them are a mess. They're the hardest people to do scenes with.
是的。他就像完全瘫倒了。是的。他彻底失控了。我有过笑得最厉害的一次是和明迪和雷恩拍一场戏，因为当你把明迪和雷恩放在一起时，没有人能控制局面。根本没有，这两人就是一团糟。他们是最难一起演戏的人。
They laugh the most. And when we get to this episode, I'll show you, I hope they have a blooper of it, but it reminded me of that. Well, at the end of the scene, she does say that she would like an ice cream cake. Were you burping as you said ice cream or did you have a gurgle? No. What just happened? I don't know.
他们笑得最多。等我们讲到这一集时，我会放给你们看，我希望他们有NG镜头，但这让我想起了那个。好吧，在场景结束时，她的确说她想要一个冰淇淋蛋糕。你刚才说冰淇淋时是在打嗝还是喉咙咕噜了一声？没有。刚才怎么了？我不知道。
You did this. Ice cream cake. I don't know. I didn't burp. I know. Listen, listen, you already outed me for like eating off my shirt, but I don't also like belch. Okay.
是你干的。冰淇淋蛋糕。我不知道。我没打嗝。我知道。听着，听着，你们已经曝光了我从衬衫上吃东西的事，但我才不会打嗝呢。好吧。
It wasn't a burp. People are like, Jenna doesn't wash her hands. She eats off her shirt. I don't need belching as part of my reputation now. You are the one who shared about the hand washing. Only at home. That was on you. I know, but I only don't wash my hands after a tinkle at home.
那不是打嗝。人们会说，珍娜不洗手。她从衬衫上吃东西。我可不需要打嗝成为我名声的一部分。你才是那个分享洗手事情的人。只在家里。那是你自找的。我知道，但在家里我只是小解后不洗手。
I always wash my hands after a poop. I always wash my hands after I tinkle or poop in public, but somehow I become the poster child for just never washing hands and I don't want that on me. Okay. That is not who I am. That's what she said. Oh, you said I don't want that on me. I can help it.
我大便后总是洗手。我在公共场合小解或大便后也总是洗手，但不知怎么的，我成了从不洗手的人的代名词，我可不想背上这个名声。好吧。我根本不是那样的人。她就是这么说的。哦，你说你不想背上这个。我有什么办法。
All right. I think people had forgotten about your hygiene and now you've reminded them. That's what you think. That's what you think. Remember everything. All I was going to say is I didn't think it was a belch. It sounded like a gurgle. You know how you get a gurgle in your throat.
好吧。我觉得大家已经忘了你的卫生习惯，现在你又提醒了他们。你是这么想的。你是这么想的。什么都记得。我本来想说的是，我不觉得那是打嗝。听起来像是喉咙咕噜声。你知道喉咙里怎么会有咕噜声的。
Sometimes maybe I needed to take a breath, but I pushed through it. I pushed through to finish my sentence. I'm sorry. I'm so sorry. You know what? Okay. Okay. All right.
有时可能我需要喘口气，但我硬挺过来了。我硬挺着把话说完。我很抱歉。非常抱歉。你知道吗？好吧。好吧。好吧。
We're going to take a break. Yeah. I'll get plenty of breath. You should take some water. I'm going to go wash my hands just to prove that I washed them. Okay. And then when we come back, we've got to get into this conference room. Oh, it's so good.
我们要休息一下。是的。我会好好喘气。你应该喝点水。我要去洗手，以证明我确实洗了。好吧。然后当我们回来时，我们得进这个会议室。哦，太棒了。
And these balloons and streamers, we'll be back. We'll be back. Are you ready for a birthday party? I am. Is it your birthday? It is your birthday. It is your birthday. Period.
还有这些气球和彩带，我们一会儿回来。我们一会儿回来。你准备好开生日派对了吗？我准备好了。今天是你的生日吗？今天是你的生日。今天是你的生日。句号。
Period. All right. We're in the conference room. Dwight has decorated for Kelly's birthday. It is so pitiful. It is pitiful. John is so funny when he enters the conference room. The way he holds the half inflated balloon.
句号。好吧。我们在会议室里。德怀特为凯莉的生日做了装饰。太寒酸了。太寒酸了。约翰进会议室的时候太搞笑了。他拿那个半充气气球的姿势。
Do we need to describe this room, by the way? Okay. For those of you who haven't seen the episode, I hope you watched it this week with us. Picture a conference table. It is full of half, not even half. No. There's like just maybe three breaths into a balloon that are brown, gray, silver. I feel like a little silver is in there.
顺便说一句，我们需要描述这个房间吗？好吧。对于那些没看过这一集的人，我希望你们本周和我们一起看了。想象一张会议桌。上面满是半满的，甚至连半满都算不上。不。里面大概只有往气球里吹了三口气的样子，棕色、灰色、银色。我觉得里面有一点银色。
Some sad, like brown, beige-y streamers. Dwight has just sort of clipped off and taped to the ceiling. With like beige mask and tape. No, it's regular clear tape. No. Yeah. There's mask and tape all over the conference room. It is hilarious to me.
还有一些悲伤的，类似于棕色、米色调的彩带。德怀特就是那种剪下来然后用胶带贴在天花板上。用那种米色的美纹胶纸。不，是普通的透明胶带。不。对。会议室里到处都是美纹胶带。我觉得太搞笑了。
No, it's clear tape. No. It's not. Oh, no. This is one of my favorite things about it because have you ever had like that guy that you were friends with in college, wrap a gift for you, and you're like, what did you use? Electrical tape? Yeah.
不，是透明胶带。不。才不是。哦，不，这是我最喜欢的地方之一，因为你有没有遇到过大学里那种朋友帮你包礼物，然后你会说，你用的是什么？电工胶带？是的。
What is this? Painters tape? Right. You had no clear tape? Oh, Jenna. Okay. I got to bring it up. Do we have, oh, I need a break.
这是什么？油漆工胶带？对。你没有透明胶带吗？哦，珍娜。好吧。我得提一下。我们有，哦，我需要休息一下。
Dwight, I have my laptop. She got her laptop back. I got my laptop back. Oscar Nunez. It's Jimmy Stewart. Long running, long running inside joke on the office. Long running inside joke now on office ladies. Oh, I can't wait to show you this looking tape to only make it sadder.
德怀特，我有我的笔记本电脑。她拿回她的笔记本电脑了。我拿回我的笔记本电脑了。奥斯卡·努涅斯。是吉米·斯图尔特。《办公室》里长盛不衰的内部梗。现在也是《办公室女士》里长盛不衰的内部梗。哦，我等不及要向你们展示这个看起来胶带贴得更惨的画面。
Okay. Where are you? And I have a time code because you know, I'm like that this whole conference room scene with the sad balloons and the sad streamers, it starts at eight minutes, 30 seconds. Oh, I love it so much. Mask and tape. Oh my God. That clear tape, please look at the mask and tape they use to tape up everything.
好吧。你在哪儿？我有时间码，因为你知道，我就是这样，整个会议室的场景，伴随着悲伤的气球和悲伤的彩带，从8分30秒开始。哦，我太喜欢了。美纹胶带。哦，天哪。那透明胶带，请看看他们用来贴所有东西的美纹胶带。
It is so sad looking. I am delighted at this detail that I did not notice until doing this podcast. It's one of my favorite things. I also want to point out at eight minutes, 37 seconds. Who do you see over John Shoulder? Oh, that's you, the whole accounting department. They had me come out to the copier for this scene and watch it. I'm in the background every time it pans to the bullpen because they sort of thought
看起来太悲伤了。我为这个细节感到高兴，直到做这个播客我才注意到。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。我还想指出在8分37秒。你在约翰肩膀后面看到了谁？哦，那是你，整个会计部门。他们让我为了这个场景出来到复印机旁看着。每次镜头扫到办公区时我都在背景里，因为他们大概觉得
that Angela Martin would be keeping tabs. What are they doing? How are they planning this party? What are they up to? So I watched these two grown men disintegrate into tears of laughter. I don't know how, again, we got any usable footage. They laughed so hard, Jenna, we had to pause. And this is what Rain said about it.
安吉拉·马丁会盯着他们。他们在干什么？他们是怎么筹备这个派对的？他们想搞什么鬼？所以我看着这两个成年男人笑得泪流满面。我不知道我们是怎么又拍到任何可用的素材的。他们笑得太厉害了，珍娜，我们不得不暂停。这就是雷恩对此的评价。
Ready? Yes. In his book, The Bassoon King, this is what he wrote. The longest inappropriate laughter was during the episode lecture circuit when Dwight and Jim are put in charge of the party planning committee and Dwight hangs tiny brown and gray balloons and a banner that reads it is your birthday. Rain goes on to say, John and I literally could not stop laughing. We laughed until we cried.
准备好了吗？是的。在他的书《巴松王》中，他是这么写的。最长的不合时宜的笑声发生在“讲座巡回路”那一集，当时德怀特和吉姆负责派对筹备委员会，德怀特挂了微小的棕色和灰色气球，还有一条横幅上面写着“今天是你的生日”。雷恩接着说，我和约翰简直笑得停不下来。我们笑得眼泪都流出来了。
Production needed to be shut down for a 20 minute break while we gathered ourselves and then we returned to film the scene. Just the way John picks up the sad balloon from the conference room table, I don't know how they spoke after that. I want to tell you the part I remember them laughing at is Dwight says, are you trying to hurt my feelings? And he throws the balloon, but it didn't have enough weight to travel in the air. And so the balloon with the sad streamer attached just kind of went, you're like in the air.
制作不得不暂停20分钟，让我们平复一下心情，然后我们才回去拍摄这个场景。就凭约翰从会议桌上拿起那个悲伤的气球的那个样子，我不知道他们在那之后是怎么说话的。我想告诉你们，我记得他们笑得最厉害的部分是德怀特说，你是在试图伤害我的感情吗？然后他把气球扔出去，但它没有足够的重量在空中飞行。所以那个系着悲伤彩带的气球就好像发出声音一样，你在空中。
But he was trying to throw it at John and it just wouldn't travel. You can see. I'm going to show you right now. You can see rain starting to break because I think he broke every time. Watch. What is that? It is your birthday period. It's a statement of fact.
但他本来是想把它朝约翰扔过去的，可它就是飞不远。你们可以看。我马上就让你们看。你们可以看到雷恩开始笑场了，因为我觉得他每次都笑场。看。那是什么？今天是你的生日，句号。这是一个客观事实。
Not even an exclamation point? This is more professional. It's not like she discovered a cure for cancer. I can't believe how bad this looks. Are you trying to hurt my feelings because if so, you are succeeding. Unfortunately, my feelings regenerate at twice the speed of a normal lens. Did you see that? The sad balloon is so good.
连个感叹号都没有？这样更专业。这又不是她发现了癌症的治疗方法。我真不敢相信这看起来有多糟。你是在试图伤害我的感情吗，因为如果是的话，你成功了。不幸的是，我的感情再生速度是正常人的两倍。你们看到了吗？那个悲伤的气球太棒了。
Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. So Dwight is annoyed at Jim's reaction to his decorating. And so he's like, wait, have you collected the money? You know, for the cake? Yeah. And Jim is like, I've only collected $6. Dwight's like, damn it, Jim, that's what we put in.
哦天哪。哦天哪。所以德怀特对吉姆对他装饰的反应感到恼火。于是他说，等等，你收钱了吗？你知道的，为了蛋糕？是的。然后吉姆说，我只收了6美元。德怀特说，见鬼，吉姆，那是我们塞进去的钱。
This got me thinking. Oh no. We are always wondering, where did we get the money for these parties? There is no way we took a collection for Casino Night. Well, no, but for birthday parties, there is clearly a birthday party collection budget. It's very clear that everyone is supposed to give $3. Right? Okay.
这让我陷入了思考。哦不。我们总是在想，这些派对的钱是从哪儿来的？我们绝对不可能为赌场之夜进行募捐。好吧，没有，但是对于生日派对，显然有一个生日派对募捐预算。很明显，每个人都应该给3美元。对吧？好吧。
So I counted. There are 13 people in the office, including Ryan, who's normally in the office, but minus the birthday person that would be 12 people who contribute for each birthday party, $3 per person is $36. The birthday party budget at Dunder Mifflin is $36. No, I had a gurgle. See? I had a gurgle.
所以我数了一下。办公室里有13个人，包括通常在办公室的瑞安，但减去过生日的那个人，那就是12个人为每个生日派对做贡献，每人3美元就是36美元。邓德米夫林的生日派对预算是36美元。不，我刚才喉咙咕噜了一声。看到了吗？我刚才咕噜了一声。
Angela just gurgled. I don't know if you've heard it. I had a gurgle. Okay. I don't know what. No, but you just didn't speak for a second because you were gurgling, so you needed air. Okay. I need to stop drinking fizzy water.
安吉拉刚才喉咙咕噜了一声。我不知道你们有没有听到。我刚才咕噜了一声。好吧。我不知道怎么回事。不，但你刚才有一秒钟没说话，因为你在咕噜，所以你需要空气。好吧。我得停止喝汽水了。
This is what it's telling me. Here's the thing. You're saying how much is the party planning committee budget? The birthday party budget is $36. Okay. I think that's true, except there have been episodes where people go to Angela for petty cash, and I think Angela's not helping these guys at all, so maybe like Phyllis, she wants to see them fail.
这就是它告诉我的。事情是这样的。你是说派对筹备委员会的预算是多少？生日派对预算是36美元。好吧。我觉得这是真的，除了有些剧集里人们去找安吉拉要零用钱，我觉得安吉拉根本不帮这几个家伙，所以也许像菲利丝一样，她想看他们出丑。
I feel like there's some petty cash for parties, but she's not going to let them in on that. That's possible. I'm just saying. I was just following this thread, you know? Yeah. And here's where it got me. Did I take the one down here? Your sales?
我觉得派对是有一些零用钱的，但她不会让他们知道。这倒有可能。我只是随口说说。我只是顺着这个思路往下想，你知道吗？是的。然后这就是我的思路到的地方。我把下面的这个拿下来了吗？你的销售额？
No. I took it. Birthday party budget is $36 or another theory, whatever you want. I feel like I'm getting some sass. I'm not giving you any sass. I feel a little sass. I'm just saying. I think there is some extra cash.
没有。我拿了。生日派对预算是36美元，或者另一种理论，随便你。我觉得我受到了一点顶撞。我可没有顶撞你。我觉得有点被顶撞了。我只是说说而已。我觉得确实有一些额外的现金。
Can I give you a fan question from Preston G? Yes. Yes. Preston would like to know, who came up with the It Is Your Birthday period slogan? Oh, Preston, I want to know that too. Mindy. Mindy! I texted her.
我能问你一个来自普雷斯顿·G的粉丝提问吗？可以。可以。普雷斯顿想知道，是谁想出了“今天是你的生日，句号”这句口号的？哦，普雷斯顿，我也想知道。明迪。明迪！我给她发了信息。
She said it was her. Genius. Genius. Genius lady. So, so good. Perfect too. Perfect that that's what Dwight would write. Perfect.
她说那是她想的。天才。天才。天才女士。太棒了。太完美了。这正是德怀特会写的话，太完美了。
I have a shameless plug. What for? Our merch. Oh! Because we sell the most adorable It Is Your Birthday wrapping paper and gift bags over on OfficeLadies.com. We do. They have the sad balloons and streamers.
我有个厚颜无耻的广告。卖什么的？我们的周边商品。哦！因为我们在 OfficeLadies.com 上出售最可爱的“今天是你的生日”包装纸和礼品袋。我们确实有。上面有悲伤的气球和彩带。
They are so cute and then, of course, we had to include It Is Your Wedding. And It Is Your Baby Shower. Yes, with sad balloons. If you want to have some sad wrapping paper for your baby shower, we got you covered. Listen, if the person receiving the gift is an Office fan, they will like it. They will love it. We also have a Nifty Gifties bag. You got to have a Nifty Gifties.
它们太可爱了，然后，当然，我们不得不加入“今天是你的婚礼”。还有“今天是你的迎婴派对”。是的，带有悲伤的气球。如果你想为你的迎婴派对准备一些悲伤的包装纸，我们为你准备好了。听着，如果收礼物的人是《办公室》的粉丝，他们会喜欢的。他们一定会爱不释手的。我们还有精美礼品袋。你得备一个精美礼品袋。
You can tell we're two ladies who like to wrap a gift. We do. OfficeLadies.com. Go to shop. Okay. Shameless plug. Should we head over to Utica for a second and check in? Because Pam and Michael have just arrived.
你可以看出我们是两个喜欢包装礼物的女士。我们确实是。OfficeLadies.com。去商店。好吧。无耻的广告结束。我们要不要去尤蒂卡待一会儿，看看情况？因为帕姆和迈克尔刚到。
They're taking a photo outside of the branch. I guess we're documenting this trip. Oh, yeah. Are you kidding? I feel like Michael is a scrapbooker. Yeah. Pam's in charge of all of the bags and taking pictures. When they arrive, Rolando.
他们正在分公司外面拍照。我想我们在记录这次旅行。哦，真的吗。开什么玩笑？我觉得迈克尔是个做剪贴簿的人。是的。帕姆负责所有的包和拍照。当他们到达时，罗兰多。
Rolando is back. Adam Jamal Craig. So good. Remember he was in season four in Branch Wars? Well he's serving up a bit of sass because he says you're late. Yeah. A lot of people pointed out that Michael introduces Pam to Rolando even though we know from Branch Wars that she knows him.
罗兰多回来啦。亚当·贾马尔·克雷格。太棒了。还记得他在第四季的“分公司大战”里吗？嗯，他有点语带讥讽，因为他说你们迟到了。是的。很多人指出，迈克尔把帕姆介绍给罗兰多，尽管我们从“分公司大战”中知道她认识他。
And the thing that got cut out was that Rolando and I were supposed to share like a little look. Right. But it didn't make it. It's so played for me though that Michael would forget who Pam knows and doesn't know and he just doesn't really pay attention to what other people do at his own company. Oh, totally. This is also when Michael decides to offer Pam a little trick for getting through any
而被剪掉的内容是罗兰多和我本该有一个小小的眼神交流。对。但没播出来。不过对我来说，迈克尔会忘记谁是帕姆认识的人、谁不认识，而且他根本不关心公司里其他人都在做什么，这很符合他的作风。哦，完全是。这也是迈克尔决定给帕姆出个小招，好让她克服见到凯伦时可能会感到的任何紧张情绪的时候。
nerves she might be feeling about seeing Karen. Yeah. She should just picture her naked. Yeah. And then Karen enters. A very pregnant Karen. Yes. And then Michael.
是的。她只需要想象凯伦没穿衣服的样子。是的。然后凯伦进来了。一个大腹便便的凯伦。是的。然后是迈克尔。
Oh my gosh, Michael. He's so good. Is it Jim's? Yeah. And he said, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm just trying to calculate in my head when's the last time you had sex with Jim. He said that out loud. He said, it was it 10 months ago?
哦天哪，迈克尔。他太逗了。是吉姆的吗？是的。他说，对不起，对不起，我只是在脑子里计算你上次和吉姆发生性关系是什么时候。他居然大声说出来了。他说，是10个月前吗？
To two women that have dated him or dating him, so awkward. We had a fan question from Mickey S. Was Rashida Jones actually pregnant in this episode? No. That was Fakie Belly. Fakie Belly. Well, they're going to move into the conference room. Michael's going to start a show. But first he has a phone call.
对两个和他约会过或正在约会的女人来说，太尴尬了。我们有一个来自米奇·S的粉丝提问。拉什达·琼斯在这一集里真的怀孕了吗？没有。那是假肚子。假肚子。好吧，他们要进会议室了。迈克尔要开始表演了。但首先他有个电话。
Yes. He has a dramatic phone call and then explains to the group that he just learned his father died. Yeah. But then he says, I'm just kidding. But you bought it, you bought it, and you can't return it, or can you? He got their attention. What does it have to do with selling paper?
是的。他接了一个戏剧性的电话，然后向大家解释说他刚得知他父亲去世了。是的。但随后他说，我开玩笑的。但你们信了，你们信了，而且你们退不了货了，还是说你们能？他成功吸引了大家的注意。这跟卖纸有什么关系？
I don't know. But we had a huge fan catch from three people, Rebecca N, Evan H, and Lauren B all noticed that when Michael takes this pretend phone call, in the background, I clocked it at nine minutes 39 seconds, you can see Utica's industrial printer is chained with a padlock. Oh, no way. And there is a sign requesting employees to report any suspicious behavior. And this is a callback to the time that Michael and Dwight tried to steal Utica's printer back in Branch Wars.
我不知道。但我们收到了来自三个人的巨大的粉丝捕捉，丽贝卡·N、埃文·H和劳伦·B都注意到，当迈克尔接这个假装的电话时，在背景里，我记录时间是9分39秒，你可以看到尤蒂卡的工业打印机被一把挂锁锁上了。哦，不会吧。还有一个标牌，要求员工报告任何可疑行为。这呼应了迈克尔和德怀特在“分公司大战”中试图偷回尤蒂卡的打印机的那一次。
That's amazing. It is. That is amazing. It is such a tiny. That is such a small detail. I know. And it's such a small thing. Oh, I'm delighted by that.
太神奇了。确实。太神奇了。这真是一个极其微小的细节。我知道。而且这是一件这么小的事。哦，我对这个细节感到高兴。
Yeah. I love that. It's amazing. Well, Karen, she has to say something. Michael's being so ridiculous. Yeah. And she's like, Michael, this whole sort of shenanigan at the top here just makes us think you're a liar.
是的。我太喜欢了。太神奇了。好吧，凯伦，她不得不说点什么。迈克尔太荒谬了。是的。她说，迈克尔，这一开场的一整套恶作剧只会让我们觉得你是个骗子。
And he's like, hold up, would a liar bring Minnie Mounds bars? And then you sadly throw them at everyone. Okay. Jenna, there are a lot of bloopers of you doing this. I know because every time I did it, I would burst out laughing. And I had many conversations with Ken Quapas and Mindy Kaling about this. I had to sit there for a long time with these Minnie Mounds bars in my hand. Hiding them.
而他说，等一下，骗子会带迷你曼兹巧克力棒吗？然后你悲伤地把它们扔向每个人。好吧，珍娜，有很多你做这个动作的NG镜头。我知道，因为每次我这么做时，我都会忍不住大笑。我和肯·夸帕斯以及明迪·卡林就此进行过多次谈话。我得拿着这些迷你曼兹巧克力棒在手里坐很长时间。把它们藏起来。
Hiding them. And Mindy thought it would be especially funny if I just did it very matter of factly. And of course it was. And it made us laugh every time. Sometimes I wouldn't even get to the throwing part, just me standing up. We would start laughing. I mean, the Mounds bars were getting very melty because I was holding them for so long. The way you threw them was so awkward.
藏起来。明迪觉得如果我表现得非常公事公办，会特别搞笑。当然确实如此。这让我们每次都笑。有时候我甚至还没到扔的那一步，仅仅是我站起来。我们就会开始笑。我的意思是，曼兹巧克力棒变得非常融化，因为我拿了太久。你扔它们的方式太尴尬了。
It was unnatural. It hit people. Yeah. So funny. Well, Angela, this is also not the first time that Michael has thrown candy at people. He loves to throw candy during a presentation. If you remember in business school, he threw a bunch of candy at the students in Ryan's business school class.
太不自然了。砸到人了。是的。太搞笑了。嗯，安吉拉，这也是迈克尔第一次向人们扔糖果。他很喜欢在演讲时扔糖果。如果你还记得在商学院那集，他向瑞安商学院班上的学生扔了一堆糖果。
Yes. He loves to use candy to make a point about paper sales. Well, I couldn't resist Jenna when I heard Minnie Mounds bars. I had to look up the origin of the Minnie Mounds bar. Oh, I'm fascinated. I love a Mounds bar. I ate many of the Mounds bars that day, I should say. Are you Mounds bar or Almond Joy?
是的。他喜欢用糖果来阐述关于纸张销售的观点。嗯，珍娜，当我听到迷你曼兹巧克力棒时，我简直无法抗拒。我不得不去查一下迷你曼兹巧克力棒的起源。哦，我很着迷。我很喜欢曼兹巧克力棒。那天我吃了很多曼兹巧克力棒，我得这么说。你是曼兹巧克力棒派还是杏仁欢乐豆派？
No, no, no, no, no. Okay. Don't throw any nuts in my dark chocolate and coconut treats. Can we play the jingle, please, that will live in your brain forever? Sometimes you feel like a nut. Sometimes you don't. Almond Joy's got nuts. Mounds don't.
不，不，不，不，不。好吧。不要在我的黑巧克力和椰子零食里扔任何坚果。我们能放一下那首会永远留在你脑海里的广告歌吗？有时候你觉得自己像个坚果。有时候你觉得不像。杏仁欢乐豆有坚果。曼兹没有。
Yeah, I never feel like a nut. You never feel like a nut. I am also a Minnie Mounds bar person. I love the dark chocolate. I love it. But let's start our story, guys. How did we get the Minnie Mounds bar? Our story starts with Peter Paul Halogen.
是的，我从来不觉得自己像个坚果。你从来不觉得自己像个坚果。我也是个迷你曼兹巧克力棒迷。我喜欢黑巧克力。我太喜欢了。但让我们开始我们的故事吧，伙计们。我们是怎么得到迷你曼兹巧克力棒的？我们的故事始于彼得·保罗·哈洛根。
He was a candy manufacturer in New Haven, Connecticut in the early 20th century. He was born in Armenia, and he immigrated to the U.S. in 1890 and opened a candy shop. He would sell candy bars to the U.S. Army, and they would put them in the soldier's monthly rations during World War I. And then they loved the candy bar so much when they came home, they wanted more. So after the success of that, he teamed with five other Armenian investors to form the Peter Paul Candy Manufacturing Company. They then made a very smart purchase.
他是20世纪初康涅狄格州纽黑文的一位糖果制造商。他出生于亚美尼亚，1890年移民美国并开了一家糖果店。他向美国陆军出售糖果棒，他们会在第一次世界大战期间将它们放入士兵每月的口粮中。然后士兵们回家后太喜欢这种糖果棒了，他们想要更多。所以在取得成功后，他与另外五名亚美尼亚投资者合作成立了彼得·保罗糖果制造公司。随后他们进行了一次非常明智的收购。
They purchased a candy line from candy maker Vincent Natito, who created the original Mounds bar. He was selling it for five cents. Oh, full size, five cents. They're not very big. But a full-size bar is two. He sold one. It was always a Minnie.
他们从糖果制造商文森特·纳蒂托那里收购了一条糖果生产线，后者创造了最初的曼兹巧克力棒。他当时以五美分的价格出售。哦，标准装，五美分。它们其实不大。但标准装是两个。他卖一个。一直都是迷你的。
It was always a Minnie. Okay. And then Peter Paul actually just started selling it in a pack of two for ten cents. I wish you could see Angela's hands right now. I'm showing two Mounds bars. Two Minnie. Here, you want to take my pictures? I wanted to show Jenna what it would look like.
一直都是迷你的。好吧。然后彼得·保罗实际上开始以两包十美分的价格出售它。我真希望你们现在能看到安吉拉的手。我正拿着两根曼兹巧克力棒。两个迷你装。给你，你想拍我的照片吗？我想向珍娜展示它会是什么样子。
Too many Mounds bars. There it is. Okay. Well, Jenna, during World War II, the Peter Paul Candy Manufacturing Company was faced with a severe shortage of sugar and coconut, right? Oh. World War II, they had normally been shipped from the Philippines, then the war broke out. So the company began sourcing coconut from the Caribbean using its own fleet of small
太多的迷你曼兹巧克力棒。就是这样。好吧，珍娜，在第二次世界大战期间，彼得·保罗糖果制造公司面临着严重的糖和椰子供应短缺，对吧？哦。第二次世界大战期间，它们通常是从菲律宾运来的，后来战争爆发了。于是该公司开始利用自己的小型船队从加勒比海采购椰子，
vessels to transport coconut supplies to the US. They were nicknamed the Mounds Flea Fleet. There were about seven ships small enough to avoid detailed scrutiny by the German naval war vessels. My gosh. All of this just to get coconut for some candy. Wait, it gets better. I have to say, if you're a ship captain during World War II, are you risking your life to
将椰子供应品运往美国。他们被昵称为曼兹跳蚤船队。大约有七艘船，小到足以避开德国海军战舰的详细审查。我的天哪。这一切居然只是为了给一些糖果弄点椰子。等等，还有更精彩的。我必须说，如果你是二战期间的船长，你会冒着生命危险给人们带椰子吗？
bring people coconut? Hold up. Okay. I guess you are. The Flea Fleet, as it was called, was so... Flea like flea, L-E-E? F-L-E-A. A little flea fleet.
等一下。好吧。我想你是会的。这个跳蚤船队，正如它被称为的那样，太……跳蚤就像跳蚤，L-E-E？F-L-E-A。一个小跳蚤船队。
It's a little fleet. It's a flea fleet. Oh, a teeny tiny. It's a tiny fleet. Got it. It was so small in size, it posed no threat to the German U-boats that were patrolling the Atlantic waters. But what the German naval commanders did not know was that the crew of these vessels were
这是一个小船队。这是一个跳蚤船队。哦，微型。这是一个极小的船队。明白了。它的规模太小了，对在大西洋水域巡逻的德国U型潜水艇不构成任何威胁。但德国海军指挥官们不知道的是，这些船只的船员们
also gathering more than coconuts. They were gathering valuable intelligence about the German's fleet movements and sharing it with the American armed forces. Wait one moment. What you're telling me is that while collecting supplies to make one of my favorite candies, these folks were also providing important war intelligence to the United States government during World War II. Yeah.
不仅在收集椰子。他们还在收集关于德国舰队动向的重要情报，并将其分享给美国武装部队。等一下。你的意思是，在收集制作我最喜欢的糖果之一的原料的同时，这些家伙还在二战期间向美国政府提供重要的战争情报？是的。
The Minnie Mounds Bar. I'm telling you, I was fascinated by all of this. They also dropped all of their other production of candies and just concentrated on the Mounds Bar because it was so popular. And the U.S. military purchased as much as 80% of their output by 1944. They would package 5 million candy bars monthly into combat rations. Wow. Yeah.
迷你曼兹巧克力棒。我跟你说，我对这一切着迷极了。他们还放弃了所有其他糖果的生产，专心生产曼兹巧克力棒，因为它太受欢迎了。到1944年，美国军方购买了他们高达80%的产量。他们每月将500万根糖果棒打包进作战口粮中。哇。是的。
And now, as we know, over the years, Peter Paul, they added several more things to their line, including the Almond Joy, which they're often sold together. But that's the story of the Minnie Mounds Bar. They're now owned by the Hershey Company. You can still enjoy them today. Isn't that an amazing story? I would like to enjoy one today. So would I.
现在，正如我们所知，多年来，彼得·保罗在他们的产品线中增加了更多的东西，包括杏仁欢乐豆，它们经常一起出售。但这就是迷你曼兹巧克力棒的故事。它们现在归好时公司所有。你今天依然可以享用它们。这不是一个神奇的故事吗？我今天想吃一个。我也是。
The Mounds Flea Fleet. Wow. You guys, you can learn more about it at Connecticuthistory.org. Fascinating. I have to say, I also love that it's an East Coast candy because it tracks with our show. It does. That Michael would be supporting, something that originated in Connecticut. Wow.
曼兹跳蚤船队。哇。你们可以在 connecticuthistory.org 上了解更多信息。太迷人了。我得说，我也很喜欢它是一种东海岸的糖果，因为这符合我们节目的调性。确实。迈克尔会支持发源于康涅狄格州的东西。哇。
There you go. The things you did not know you were going to learn today were that. I know. I definitely was not expecting that. Amazing. This is another example of our offshoot podcast, Two Ladies Who Google. Yes. Two Ladies Who Love to Google.
就是这样。你今天意料之外学到的知识就是这些。我知道。我绝对没料到会是这样。太神奇了。这是我们衍生播客《两个爱用谷歌的女士》的又一个例子。是的。两个喜欢谷歌的女士。
And Tell You Things. We're fun at a dinner party, guys. We actually are. We actually are. All right. Michael has a talking head that is so good I texted it to Steve. I don't know how he did it. He explains he always wanted to become an actor and he even has his own memorization techniques.
并告诉你一些事情。我们在晚宴上会很有趣的，伙计们。我们其实真的是。我们真的是。好吧。迈克尔有一段单人访谈，好到我把它发短信给了史蒂夫。我不知道他是怎么做到的。他解释说他一直想成为一名演员，他甚至有自己的记忆技巧。
He explains that the way he learned the Pledge of Allegiance is by singing it to the tune of Old MacDonald. Steve then, as Michael sings the Pledge of Allegiance to the tune of Old MacDonald. And I don't know how he did it. I don't know how he did it. I texted to him and I said, this is an amazing performance. This is so badass. I mean, he does take a long pause.
他解释说，他学习效忠誓词的方法是把它唱成《老麦克唐纳有农场》的调子。然后史蒂夫作为迈克尔把效忠誓词唱成《老麦克唐纳》的调子。我不知道他是怎么做到的。我不知道他是怎么做到的。我发短信给他，我说，这是一场精彩绝伦的表演。这太厉害了。我的意思是，他的确停顿了很久。
This was in the script, by the way. I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the republic for which it stands, one nation under God, with a woof-woof here and a woof-woof there. I mean, that is not easy to do. Well, it is true, you guys. You put something to a song and you'll learn it. It's called a Pneumonic Device and that's a real thing. It's a real thing.
顺便说一句，这是剧本里写好的。我效忠美利坚合众国国旗及立其所本之共和国，一国，上帝之下，不可分割，自由与正义降临所有人，这里汪汪，那里汪汪。我的意思是，这可真不容易做到。好吧，千真万确，伙计们。你把一些东西配上歌曲，你就能学会它。这叫做助记设备，这是真事。这是真事。
Michael says he uses it to learn people's names. So what does he got here? He looks around the room. He's got Shirdi, Mole, Lazy Eye, Mexico, Baldi, Sugar Boobs, Black Woman. He said, I take a unique part of you and I use that to memorize your name. Baldi, your head is bald. It is hairless. It is shiny.
迈克尔说他用它来记别人的名字。那他这里有什么？他环顾房间。他有：雪莉、痣、斜眼、墨西哥、秃头、糖咪咪、黑人女性。他说，我抓住你身上独特的一个部分，我用它来记住你的名字。秃头，你的头是秃的。没有头发。亮晶晶的。
It is a reflective like a mirror. M, your name is Mark. And he says, yes, yes. And Karen said, you know what, this is all really offensive. Guest star alert, Mark, aka Baldi, was played by Brian Patrick Mulligan. He has an extensive career playing famous historical figures. Like who? Al Capone.
就像镜子一样反光。M，你的名字是马克。他说，是的，是的。凯伦说，你知道吗，这真的太冒犯了。客串明星预警，马克，也就是秃头，由布莱恩·帕特里克·马利根饰演。他有着扮演著名历史人物的丰富职业生涯。比如谁？阿尔·卡彭。
Oh. Alfred Hitchcock. Teddy Roosevelt. He has played Ben Franklin in three different TV shows, including on Jimmy Kimmel Live. He just played WC Fields in a movie, but his most frequently played person is former Vice President Dick Cheney. Wow. He has played Dick Cheney in six episodes of The Tonight Show with Jay Leno and 10 times
哦。阿尔弗雷德·希区柯克。西奥多·罗斯福。他在三个不同的电视节目中扮演过本杰明·富兰克林，包括在吉米·坎摩尔直播秀上。他刚刚在一部电影里扮演了W·C·菲尔兹，但他扮演最多的人物是前副总统迪克·切尼。哇。他在《今夜秀》吉米·法伦主持期间6次扮演迪克·切尼，在吉米·坎摩尔秀上
on Jimmy Kimmel. Those guys love bringing Dick Cheney on. I guess so, they love bringing Brian Patrick Mulligan on as Dick Cheney. I also want you to know that mole did not have a real mole. Faky mole. Faky mole. I know this because I saw the call sheet and he had to come in 15 minutes earlier than everyone else to get that mole put on.
扮演了10次。那些家伙真喜欢把迪克·切尼搬上节目。我猜是的，他们很喜欢让布莱恩·帕特里克·马利根来扮演迪克·切尼。我还想让你们知道，那个痣并不是真正的痣。假痣。假痣。我知道这一点，因为我看到了通告单，他比其他人早到了15分钟，把那个痣贴上。
There you go. Yeah. So listen, back at Dunder Mifflin, I think we need to check in on Andy. Yeah, he's fallen in love. He has. And he needs an in, right? Before he goes and introduces himself to Julia, he's going to go down and he's going to spy on her car to see if he can learn anything about her.
就是这样。是的。所以听着，回到邓德米夫林，我觉得我们需要看看安迪怎么样了。是的，他恋爱了。他确实恋爱了。他需要一个切入点，对吧？在他去向茱莉亚自我介绍之前，他要下楼去，去监视她的车，看看能不能打听到关于她的什么信息。
Got to get intel. So he's peering in her car and he sees that she has a feist CD. Oh, this is jackpot for him. Jackpot. Then he sets off the car alarm. And then another car alarm. Yes. Well, lady, do you remember this feist song that he's going to sing later?
得收集情报。于是他在她的车窥探，看到她有一张菲斯特（Feist）的CD。哦，这对她来说是大奖。大奖。然后他触发了汽车警报。接着是另一辆汽车警报。是的，女士，你还记得他待会儿要唱的那首菲斯特的歌吗？
I do. Huge. It's called one, two, three, four. So it was written by Leslie Feist, who went professionally as feist. She's a Canadian pop singer. It came out in 2007. Anyway, I thought we should play the song for everybody. Okay.
我记得。超级火。歌名叫《1, 2, 3, 4》。这是由莱斯利·菲斯特创作的，她的艺名就是菲斯特。她是一位加拿大流行歌手。这首歌2007年发行。不管怎样，我觉得我们应该把这首歌放给大家听。好吧。
Here is feist one, two, three, four. One, two, three, four. Tell me that you love me more. Sleepless, long nights. That's what my youth was for. Old teenage hopes are right at your door. Left you in the deep. But they want some more, oh, oh, oh, oh, you're changing your heart, oh, oh, oh, you know
这就是菲斯特的《1, 2, 3, 4》。1, 2, 3, 4。告诉我你更爱我。失眠的漫漫长夜。那是我的青春所为。旧日的青涩愿望就在你的门前。把你留在深渊。但他们想要更多，哦，哦，哦，哦，你在改变你的心，哦，哦，哦，你知道
who you are. It's so good. So, like peppy, the song was nominated for two Grammy Awards and feist was nominated for Best New Artist and Best Pop Vocal Album. It was so huge. She did a spin on it for Sesame Street. Okay. I didn't want to say anything, but this is where I remember it.
你是谁。太棒了。这首歌非常欢快，曾获得两项格莱美奖提名，菲斯特获得了最佳新人奖和最佳流行演唱专辑提名。太火了。她还为《芝麻街》改编了这首歌。好吧。我本来不想说什么，但这就是我记住它的地方。
This was your feist moment. This was my feist moment. I mean, I actually feel like I heard it here first on Sesame Street, and then I was like, oh, that's what people are talking about, because Isabel loved Sesame Street. Well, I pulled a clip of it on Sesame Street. Oh, it's going to bring back all the feels for me. I remember, oh, we watched this over and over. We're going to learn to count, you guys, to the number four.
这是你的菲斯特时刻。这是我的菲斯特时刻。我的意思是，我实际上觉得我是先在这里，《芝麻街》上听到它的，然后我想，哦，这就是大家在讨论的歌，因为伊莎贝尔超爱《芝麻街》。好吧，我截取了一段它在《芝麻街》里的片段。哦，这会勾起我所有的情感。我记得，哦，我们一遍又一遍地看这个。我们要学会数数，伙计们，数到数字四。
One, two, three, four monsters walking across the floor, I love counting, counting to the number four. Oh, you're counting, counting with me, to one less than five and one more than three. Oh, counting to four, oh, let's count some more. Okay. Why am I crying? Oh my gosh, because our kids were little and they love Sesame Street and they're older now.
一、二、三、四，小怪物走过地板，我爱数数，数到数字四。哦，你在数数，和我一起数，数到比五少一、比三多一的数字。哦，数到四，哦，让我们再数一会儿。好吧。我为什么在哭？哦天哪，因为我们的孩子那时还小，他们超爱《芝麻街》，而他们现在长大了。
I didn't even have a kid then. I didn't even have a kid then. But just, I could hear the monsters start to sing, and I just could, they're, they're they all are. And I don't know. I know. You're right. I don't know anymore.
我当时甚至还没有孩子。我当时甚至还没孩子。但只要听到小怪物们开始唱歌，我就可以，它们，它们都在那里。我不知道。我知道。你说的对。我不知道了。
So maybe it just, I don't know. I know. Listen, I found a video where I, Isabelle was little and I was doing Elmo and I was doing, I was like, I was going, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, Elmo's world. Oh yes. We sang that song all the time. I know. Yeah.
所以也许只是，我不知道。我知道。听着，我找到了一段视频，里面伊莎贝尔还小，我在模仿埃尔莫，我在，我就在说，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，啦，埃尔莫的世界。哦是的。我们一直唱那首歌。我知道。是的。
Let's have a baby. No, I'm kidding. Oh my God. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. No. My daughter's been asking for a baby. Oh my gosh.
我们生个孩子吧。不，开玩笑的。哦天哪。我开玩笑的。我开玩笑的。不。我女儿一直在要个孩子。哦天哪。
My little sister. Listen, whenever I want to make my, I didn't know how to explain periamentopause to her. But I was like, mama doesn't make any eggs anymore, baby. Mama. Let me, let's talk about cobwebs. I want to describe to you what a cobweb situation is. Well, Andy is going to interrupt Stanley's meeting.
我的小妹妹。听着，每当我想让我的，我不知道怎么向她解释围绝经期。但我就觉得，妈妈不再产生任何卵子了，宝贝。妈妈。让我，我们来谈谈蜘蛛网。我想向你描述什么是蜘蛛网状况。好吧，安迪要去打断斯坦利的会议。
He's going to bring them both some coffees. He's put one, two, three, four Splendors in Stanley's coffee. Yeah, he's like, one, two, three, four Splendors in your coffee Stanley. None in yours, Julia, because I don't know how you take it. I thought Julia was absolutely perfect. Oh, I did too. Guest star alert Julia was played by Erica Tazelle. I totally recognized her from the show Justified.
他给他们俩都带了咖啡。他在斯坦利的咖啡里放了一份、两份、三份、四份代糖（Splendas）。是的，他说，一、二、三、四份代糖在你的咖啡里，斯坦利。你的没有，茱莉亚，因为我不知道你是怎么喝的。我觉得茱莉亚简直完美。哦，我也觉得。客串明星预警，茱莉亚由埃里卡·塔泽尔饰演。我完全认出了她是美剧《火线警探》里的。
She played Rachel Brooks. Erica is a classically trained actress. She graduated with an MFA from the NYU acting program. Her professional acting debut was at the New York Shakespeare Festival. And since we've been tracking these things, I'll have you know she was not on Monk, but she has been on both law and order and law and order special victims unit. I loved all of her reactions to Andy. They were so perfect.
她饰演瑞秋·布鲁克斯。埃里卡是一位受过古典训练的女演员。她毕业于纽约大学表演专业，获得MFA学位。她的职业表演处女作是在纽约莎士比亚节。既然我们一直在追踪这些事情，我可以告诉你，她没有演过《神探阿蒙》，但她演过《法律与秩序》和《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》。我太喜欢她对安迪的所有反应了。简直太完美了。
And this whole thing has just completely ticked off Stanley. He's like, what are you doing? He pulls Andy aside. And Andy says he loves Julia with all his heart. Yeah, all his heart. Stanley is like, if you really love her fine, give me two of your clients. You can have this client. Yeah.
而这一切彻底惹恼了斯坦利。他说，你在干什么？他把安迪拉到一边。安迪说他全心全意地爱着茱莉亚。是的，全心全意。斯坦利说，如果你真的爱她，好吧，把你的两个客户给我。你可以拿走这个客户。是的。
So Andy takes over the meeting in a very awkward way. He wonders, where should we send your invoices to your boyfriend? Right. Because we certainly could. And she's so matter of fact, he's like, no, you can send it to my work address. This is for work. Yeah. But Andy does find out she does not have a boyfriend.
于是安迪以一种非常尴尬的方式接管了会议。他纳闷，我们该把你的发票寄到哪里？寄给你的男朋友吗？对。因为我们当然可以。而她表现得非常实事求是，她说，不用，你可以寄到我的工作地址。这是为了工作。是的。但安迪确实发现她没有男朋友。
And then he kind of panics. He's so excited. And then he gets advice from Creed. Why Creed? I don't know. Why would you go to Creed for advice? Creed's like, say no more. Just go in for a kiss.
然后他有点恐慌。他太兴奋了。然后他从克里德那里得到了建议。为什么是克里德？我不知道。你怎么会去找克里德征求意见呢？克里德说，不用多说。直接上去亲她。
That's how I got squeaky from. Yeah. I didn't know who that was. I had to Google it. I didn't know who it was. No. Yeah. Now I do.
我就是这么搞定 squeaky from 的。是的。我不知道那是谁。我不得不去谷歌搜索。我不知道那是谁。没有。是的。现在我知道了。
Yeah. Well, Charles Manson. She was part of the Manson family. Right. Yeah. She went to jail. She tried to assassinate Gerald Ford. Right.
是的。好吧，查尔斯·曼森。她是曼森家族的成员。对。是的。她坐过牢。她试图暗杀杰拉尔德·福特。对。
President Ford. Right. She was not part of the Tate Lobby Onka murders, but she did try to assassinate Gerald Ford. So I guess Creed kissed her. And he says, have I ever steered you wrong, Jim? Yeah. Just go in and kiss her. Just do it.
福特总统。对。她没有参与泰特·拉ビ安卡谋杀案，但她确实试图暗杀杰拉尔德·福特。所以我想克里德亲了她。他说，我什么时候把你带沟里过，吉姆？是的。直接上去亲她。直接这么做。
Then just, you know, that's what you should do. When he called Andy Jim, if you're Andy, wouldn't you think, hmm, there's many reasons to her red flags? There's so many red flags. So many red flags. Well, for whatever reason, Andy is going to take Creed's advice. He's going to walk Julia to the car. He forgot his coat.
然后就，你知道的，这就是你应该做的。当他管安迪叫吉姆时，如果你是安迪，难道你不会想，嗯，有很多理由说明这是红灯吗？有太多的红灯了。太多的红灯了。好吧，不管出于什么原因，安迪决定听从克里德的建议。他要送茱莉亚去停车场。他忘了拿外套。
Could he run back in and get it real quick? Because he's very, very cold. Julia says, my car's right here, I think. Thanks for walking me down, but I'm good. And then when he gets her to the car, he goes in for a kiss, Andy. Come on. This woman has had to put up with so much in this meeting. And now this also like she could write him up.
他能跑回里面去迅速拿一下吗？因为他非常非常冷。茱莉亚说，我的车就在这儿，我想。谢谢你送我下来，但我很好。然后当他把她送到车旁时，他直接凑上去亲她，安迪。拜托。这个女人在这个会议上已经忍受了太多了。现在这也，她完全可以写报告举报他。
I know. He could lose his job. Andy. Don't listen to Creed, Andy. They do lose the account. Yeah. He has a talking head. So he kind of lost in every way today.
我知道。他可能会丢掉工作。安迪。别听克里德的，安迪。他们的确丢了这个客户。是的。他有一段单人访谈。所以他今天可以说是全方位失败了。
He lost three accounts. He lost two that he gave to Stanley. Oh, yeah. One that Stanley gave to him. And he kind of showed his ass. Yeah. He did. Well, speaking of showing your ass, Karen has asked Michael to leave the conference room
他失去了三个客户。他弄丢了两个给斯坦利带去的。哦，是的。还有一个是斯坦利给他的。而且他可以说是把脸都丢光了。是的。他确实丢了。好吧，说到丢脸，凯伦要求迈克尔离开会议室
and come to her office. It's like getting called to the principal's office. And he is trying very hard to explain that he had a whole bit with a chainsaw that he hasn't been able to do. And Karen's like, you know what? Why don't you just put it all in an email and I'll send it to my team. And he's like, I can't put a chainsaw in an email, Karen. I can't do it.
去她的办公室。就像被叫到校长办公室一样。他非常努力地解释说他有一个关于电锯的整套表演，但他一直没能演出来。凯伦说，你知道吗？你为什么不把它全写在一封邮件里，然后我发给我的团队。而他说，我没法把一把电锯塞进一封邮件里，凯伦。我做不到。
This is when Pam and Karen are going to have a little bonding moment. Yeah. It's so sweet. Pam says, when are you do? And Karen says, I'm doing a month. Yeah. Michael says, who did this to you? Who did this to you, Karen?
这时帕姆和凯伦将有一个温馨的联络感情的时刻。是的。太甜了。帕姆说，你预产期是什么时候？凯伦说，我还有一个月。是的。迈克尔说，是谁对你做出这种事的？是谁对你做出这种事的，凯伦？
And she's like my husband. He's a dermatologist. We met at a bar. And then they have all these cute photos. They have one where they're like dressed like hot dogs. Yes, a hot dog in a hamburger. Yeah. It's very cute.
她说，我丈夫。他是皮肤科医生。我们在酒吧认识的。然后他们有很多可爱的照片。他们有一张穿着像热狗一样的衣服。是的，一个热狗和一个汉堡。是的。非常可爱。
We had a lot of fan questions about this. Everyone wants to know who is the man in the photo? Who is Dan, the dermatologist who is married to Karen? Well, it was played by writer Dan Gore. Yeah. He was a writer on Parks and Recreation. Yes. And he had been working with Mike Schurer and Greg Daniels as they developed that
我们对此有很多粉丝提问。每个人都想知道照片里的那个男人是谁？嫁给凯伦的皮肤科医生丹是谁？嗯，是由编剧丹·戈尔（Dan Gore）饰演的。是的。他是《公园与游憩》的编剧。是的。他一直在和迈克尔·舒尔（Mike Schur）以及格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起开发那个
show. And we had seen him a few times on set and in the writer's room meeting with those guys. And he came to set one day when we were shooting on the stages and he and Rashida dressed up in all these different outfits and they went around and took pictures. It was amazing. It was amazing. Well, you know, now Karen is going to ask about Jim.
节目。我们在片场和编剧室里开会时见过他几次。有一天我们在片场拍戏时他来到现场，他和雷什达穿各种不同的服装，四处走动并拍照。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，你们知道，现在凯伦要问起吉姆了。
Yes. It's a little bit of tension, but Pam says we're engaged. And Karen is just earnestly happy for them. Yeah. Rashida really sold it. Because I think as an audience, you're like, oh, what's that? And she's like, she has so moved on. She has a whole life.
对。有一点点紧张，但帕姆说我们订婚了。凯伦真的很为他们高兴。是的。拉什达演得真好。因为我觉得作为观众，你会想，哦，那是什么？而她却表现得，她已经完全向前看了。她有了全新的人生。
She's happy. And it gives Pam closure. Yeah. I don't know about you, Angie, but I am happy if someone I have broken up with finds like a new relationship with someone else and they're in love because I'm like, yeah, that's why we broke up because we weren't a match. And then you found your match. I don't have a lot of hard feelings about stuff.
她很幸福。这给了帕姆一个了结。是的。安吉，我不知道你怎么样，但如果我和某人分手后，他找到了新恋情并且坠入爱河，我会很高兴，因为我会觉得，对，这就是我们分手的原因，因为我们不合适。然后你找到了你的真爱。我对这些事没有什么不好的情绪。
And I've had some messy breakups, you know, and even still, I don't know. I just, I think I am more Karen on this one. I'm like, well, great. I'm glad that worked out because, you know, good. It wasn't meant to be for me and Jim, but it's for you and Jim. Right. No, I think life is short. My grandmother used to always say every pot has its lid.
我经历过一些糟糕的分手，你知道的，即便如此，我不知道。我只是觉得，在这件事上我更像凯伦。我会想，太好了。我很高兴事情进展顺利，因为，你知道的，挺好的。我和吉姆注定无缘，但你和吉姆在一起了。对吧。不，我认为人生苦短。我奶奶过去常说，什么样的锅配什么样的人。
And I want everyone to find their lid. Yeah. I wasn't your lid. I fell in the water where I was too big. I was too big for your pot. Yeah. Or too small for your pot. I didn't fit your pot.
我希望每个人都能找到自己的另一半。对。我不是你的那个盖子。我掉进水里时发现自己太大了。你的锅装不下我。对。或者对你的锅来说我太小了。我配不上你的锅。
Let's break it down some more. I'm trying to see if there's a that's what she said in there, but I can't find it. My lid fit your pot perfect. No. I think it would be your pot fit my lid just right. That's what she said. I don't think either of them are real strong. That's what she said.
让我们再细细琢磨一下。我在想里面有没有一句“她刚才就是这么说的”，但我找不到。我的盖子和你的锅完美契合。不对。我觉得应该是你的锅和我的盖子刚刚好。她刚才就是这么说的。我觉得这两句都不太符合“她刚才就是这么说的”的标准。
We should let it go. No, let's stick with it. No, let's try it. Let's try a few more. Let's try a few more. We'll find it. We'll find it. Everyone, if you find it, will you email us?
我们算了吧。不，我们坚持一下。不，我们试试。再多试几个。再多试几个。我们会找到的。我们会找到的。大家伙儿，如果你们找到了，能给我们发邮件吗？
Oh, no. What are you asking for? I don't know. All right. Some interesting mail to read. That's for sure. That's for sure. I don't know where we are.
哦，不。你在要求什么？我不知道。好吧。有一些有趣的信件要读。那是肯定的。那是肯定的。我不知道我们在哪儿了。
We've hopped around. Well, I'll tell you. Okay. Michael and Pam are going to leave the Utica branch. All right. Michael gives his lecture a B plus. He says Karen is mean. Pam says I like her.
我们东奔西跑的。好吧，我告诉你。好啦。迈克尔和帕姆要离开尤蒂卡分公司了。好吧。迈克尔给自己的讲座打了个B加。他说凯伦很刻薄。帕姆说我挺喜欢她的。
And then Pam says she's glad she came along and that seeing Karen gave her closure. Well, that's going to come back because as they're driving away, Michael tells Pam, you know what? I never got closure with Holly. She was the love of my life and I never got closure. So Pam says, I think we should blow off this lecture in Rochester and go to Nashua instead. Michael says, let's do it. Pam is like, yes, screw them.
然后帕姆说很高兴能同行，看到凯伦让她放下了心结。好吧，这事儿还没完，因为当他们开车离开时，迈克尔告诉帕姆，你知道吗？我从来没和霍莉真正了结。她是我一生的挚爱，我们之间从来没有画上句号。所以帕姆说，我觉得我们应该翘掉罗切斯特的讲座，直接去纳舒厄。迈克尔说，就这么办。帕姆就像是，太好了，管他们去死。
Let's do this. All of a sudden, Michael just got, what do the kids call it, a ride or die? He's like, yeah. Yeah. And then we have to be continued. The screen goes to black. You think it's over, but there's a tag. There's a tag.
就这么办。突然之间，迈克尔就有了——孩子们叫它什么来着？生死之交？他就像是。对。然后就是未完待续。画面黑屏了。你以为结束了，但还有个彩蛋。有个彩蛋。
Jim is asking Creed for $3 for Kelly's party. Creed says, great. I'd like to contribute. And then he hands him a $3 bill. I had to know whose face was on that $3 bill. Okay. Because, you know, Phil Shea had to make that. Yeah.
吉姆向克里德要3美元作为凯利派对的经费。克里德说，太好了。我想出份力。然后他递给吉姆一张3美元的钞票。我当时必须弄清楚那张3美元钞票上印的是谁的脸。好吧，因为，你知道的，菲尔·谢伊肯定制作了那个。对。
I paused. I looked at it. You know who I thought it was? Who? No. It looked like Brad Pitt to me. Come on. And I thought maybe it was a nod to BJ because he was doing the movie with Brad Pitt.
我暂停了。我仔细看了看。你猜我以为那是谁？谁？没有。我觉得它看起来像布拉德·皮特。拜托。我当时想，这或许是在向BJ致敬，因为他当时正和布拉德·皮特拍电影。
I don't know. I remember we talked a lot about Brad Pitt when BJ was making that movie. We all thought we might become friends with him. We were positive. We were like, BJ, bring him to set. Maybe he likes to come have lunch. Yeah. We'll be totally cool, BJ.
我不知道。我记得当BJ在拍那部电影时，我们讨论了很多关于布拉德·皮特的话题。我们都以为我们可能会和他成为朋友。我们百分之百确信。我们当时想，BJ，把他带到片场来吧。也许他喜欢来吃午饭。对。我们会表现得非常酷的，BJ。
We will be normal. Exactly. Remember, we never brought him to work. I know. We went through that with John and George Clooney too. We were like, John, we're going to be so normal around George. We're not going to bring up, you know, his place in Lake Como and that we want to go. We've read about it.
我们会表现得很正常的。没错。记得吗，我们从来没把他带到工作场所过。我知道。我们和约翰还有乔治·克鲁尼也经历过那种事。我们当时想，约翰，我们在乔治面前会表现得超级正常。我们绝不会提起，你知道的，他在科莫湖的庄园，还有我们想去那儿。我们读到过。
We won't say that. We won't say that we read about it in People Magazine. We won't say any of those things. None of those things. Well, it turns out Randy Cordray told me who's on the $3 bill. Who? George W. Bush. What?
我们不会说那个。我们不会说我们在《人物》杂志上读到过这个。我们不会说任何这些话。什么都没有。好吧，结果兰迪·科德雷告诉我3美元钞票上印的是谁。谁？小布什。什么？
I don't know. That's who Phil picked. He said Phil made it and that's who he put on it. You thought George W. Bush was Brad Pitt? I guess I did. It's time for new glasses. Get Nana some glasses. You guys, that's lecture circuit part one.
我不知道。那是菲尔选的。他说那是菲尔制作的，上面印的就是这个人。你以为小布什是布拉德·皮特？我想我当时确实是这么觉得的。该换新眼镜了。给奶奶配副眼镜吧。各位，这就是讲座巡回第一部分。
Yep. We'll be back next week with lecture circuit part two and a lot of stories about licking cats. You said that so Midwest and a lot of stories about licking cats. Yeah. Sometimes your Missouri really comes out and I live for it. Oh, here, I'll give you some Missouri. One, two, three, far, far.
对。我们下周将带着讲座巡回第二部分以及许多关于舔猫的故事回归。你这句话说得太有中西部特色了，还有许多关于舔猫的故事。对。有时候你身上的密苏里味儿真的藏不住，我太爱了。哦，来吧，我给你来点密苏里味儿。一，二，三，远，远。
We're counting to far. We're counting to far. Oh, oh. We're counting to far. There you go. See you guys next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我们数到了远。我们数到了远。哦，哦。我们数到了远。就是这样。大家下周见。感谢收听“办公室淑女”。“办公室淑女”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。有关“办公室淑女”的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。